[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
ولد القارئ محمد حمدان الملاحي بقريه
اورال باقليم تطوان شماليه المغرب وفي
الخامسه من عمره الحقته اسرته بكتاب
القريه ليقضي طفولته الاولى متنقلا بين
المدارس والكتاتيب والمحاضر القرانيه في
القرى المغربيه حريصا على حفظ القران وفهم
معانيه بالطرق التقليديه السائده في
التعليم القراني
حفظ القران كاملا ومع ذلك اصر على مزيد
تلقي علومه والغوص في معانيه واحكامه
فتنقل مرتحلا بين مدارس قرانيه في مدن
مغربيه مختلفه ناهلا العلوم الشرعيه على
يد كبار علماء المغرب ومشايخها
وحينما اشتد عوده تولى قارئنا الامامه
والتدريس في مساجد طنجه قبل انتقاله الى
بلجيكا واستقراره بها
رحلتي بدات مع القران الكريم حوالي سنه
الخامسه
من عمري حيث التحقت بالكتاب او ما يسمى
بالمسيد او المعمره وفي بعض المناطق
المحضره وهي اسماء
والمسمى واحد وهو المكان الملحق بالمسجد
في الغالب وخاصه في القرى مخصص لحفظ
القران الكريم
مرحله الاولى تبتدا
من لحظه الالتحاق
وتمتد الى ختم القران الكريم
مرتين او ثلاثه على الشيوخ
واستظهاره كاملا ثم المرحله الثانيه هذه
المرحله خاصه
بالتثبت
والاتقان والتصحيح والضبط
وهذه لا تتحقق الا
بالخروج من القريه الاولى او القبيله
الاولى
والتوجه الى قبائل ومداشيره اخرى سواء
مجاوره او بعيده حسب ما تيسر
بحثا عن الشيوخ الماهرين في حفظ القران
الكريم
ورسمه وضبطه وتجويده بعد هذه المرحله
انتقلت الى مرحله اخرى وهي المرحله
النهائيه
بعد حفظ بعض المتون الخاصه
بالرسم
والتجويد
والفقه
الى اخره وهذه المواد
العلميه كانت تدرس في المعاهد الشرعيه
ولذلك التحقت باحدى المعاهد وهو المعاهد
الديني التابع لوزاره الاوقاف والشؤون
الاسلاميه بمدينه الخميسات ومن المعاهد
ايضا المعهد
المعهد والشيخ سيد المهدي شقور العلمي
بقبيله بني حسان رحمه الله عليه بعد هذه
المرحله مباشره رشحت للامامه وتدريس ماده
التجويد بمسجد سوريا بمدينه طنجه سنه
1400 سنه 1984
الى
سنه
انتقلت الى مسجد اخر من نفس المدينه
وللمه نفسها الامامه والتدريس
ثم
هذه خلال هذه المرحله شاركت في عده
مسابقات اقليميه
ووطنيه ودوليه
واحرصت على جوائز متعدده
ثم
شاركت ايضا
في بعض الانشطه او الاسهامات
المتعلقه
بالقران الكريم وتسجيله
والتحكيمي في مسابقاته سقرا ان شاء الله
تعالى بروايه ورش عن نافع عن طريق الازرق
اعوذ بالله من الشيطان الرجيم
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
تبارك الذي جعل في السماء
بروجا
وجعل فيها سراجا
وجعل فيها
سراجا وقمرا
[موسيقى]
وهو الذي جعل الليل
والنهار خلفه لمن اراد ان يذكر او اراد
شكورا
وعباد الرحمن
الذين
يمشون على الارض هونا
واذا خاطبهم
واذا
خاطبهم
الجاهلون
قالوا سلاما
[موسيقى]
والذين
يبيتون
لردهم سجدا
قياما
والذين يقولون ربنا اصرف
عنا
عذاب جهنم
ان عذابها
والذين يقولون ربنا اصرف
عنا
عذاب ج
هنم
ان عذاب
كان غراما
انها
ساءت مستقرا
ومقاما
[موسيقى]
والذين اذا
انفقوا لم
يسرفوا ولم يقتروا
وكان بين ذلك قواما
والذين لا يدعون مع الله
[موسيقى]
الى يقتلون
ولا
يقتلون
النفس التي
حرم الله الا بالحق
ولا
يقتلون
النفس التي
حرم الله
الا
بالحق
ولا يز
نو ومن
يفعل ذلك
يلقى
اثاما
يضاعف له
العذاب يوم القيامه
[موسيقى]
يضاعف له العذاب يوم
القيامه
ويخلد
فيهم هانا
ويخلد فيه
مهانني الا
[موسيقى]
من
امن وعمل عملا
صالحا
[موسيقى]
فاولئ
ك
يبدل الله
سيدتهم حسنا
[موسيقى]
وكان الله غفورا
رحيق صدق الله العظيم
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
بعد سطوع نجمه شمال المغرب التحق القارئ
والامام والحافظ محمد حمدان الملاحي الى
الاستقرار ببلجيكا حيث يعيش حوالي نصف
مليون مغربي وليتولى الامامه والتدريس
بعدد من مساجد ومراكز العاصمه بروكسل دون
ان يقطع حبل الوصل ببلده الام المغرب فاتم
التسجيل عدد من المصاحف القرانيه التي تبث
في الاذاعات المغربيه والبلجيكيه كما
يتولى المشاركه في تحكيم المسابقات
القرانيه في بلجيكا وعموم اوروبا ضمن
انشطه المراكز الاسلاميه هناك
بعض المرحله الاخيره
المتعلقه
بالتلقي والاخذ والمشافهه
رشحت للامامه والتدريس
احدى المساجد كما قلت
بطنجه مسجد سوريا
مده سنه
1984 الى سنه
1992 حيث انتقلت الى مسجد اخر لنفسي
المهمه الامامه والتدريس دائما
هذا المسجد اسمه مسجد الامام الشاطبي رحمه
الله خلال هذه المرحله
قمت بتدريس ماده التجويد ايضا
بمعهد العلوم الشرعيه التابعه لجمعيه
التوعيه الاسلاميه بطنجه كذلك تحت اشراف
الدكتور ابراهيم بن صديق رحمه الله
وكذلك
قمت ايضا بتدريس نفس الماده بمؤسسه النور
القرانيه تحت اشراف المندوبيه الجهويه
للشؤون الاسلاميه وهذه المده لم تطل لانني
كنت استعد للسفر الى هنا
وسنه
سته اخر سنه 2006
جئت الى بلجيكا
ولازلت
اقوم بمهمه الايمان بامامه والتدريس الى
الان
وفي مسيرتي
شاركت في الاعداد في العديد من
المساهمات منها المشاركه في
المسابقه الخاصه بالتسجيل مصحف المسيره
القرانيه سنه 96 97 هذا المصحف اوذيع على
شاشتي اذاعه والتلفزه المغربيه كذلك شاركت
في المسابقه
الخاصه بتسجيل المصحف المحمدي
المرتل سنه
2002 وكذلك
قمت بتسجيل مصحف ثالث
بالاذاعه الجهويه بطنجه سنه 2005
ثم شاركت في عده
اللجان التحكيم الخاصه بالمسابقه
المحليه وكذلك الوطنيه
والدوليه بنسبه بلجيكا بالمقارنه مع
المغرب هناك اختلاف كبير
لان الوضع هنا في بلجيكا يحتاج الى مؤسسات
متكامله مستقله حتى يمكن ان تعطي اكلها
اما بالنسبه للبرامج
الموجوده في عموم المساجد بالنسبه للقران
الكريم هي برامج هي جيده لكن لا ترقى الى
مستوى المطلوب لان تحتاج الى تنظيم وتحتاج
الى الى تشجيع وتحتاج الى اشياء كثيره لان
التلاميذ لهم تكاليف اخرى ولهم مهيمات
اخرى في المدرسه البلجيكيه خلال اسبوع
كامل لذلك من الصعب
ان يكلفهم الانسان اكثر من الطاقه فلهم
برنامج هنا يوم السبت والاحد والسبت
والاحد
عطله عطله التلاميذ اذا لا يمكن ان تكلفهم
في عطلتهم اكثر من طاقتهم وهما
لهم تكاليف اخرى مطالبون بانجازها من
المدارس ولذلك
فالوضع هنا احتاج الى اعاده النظر في هذا
البرنامج ثم
تاسيس مؤسسات متكامله تدرس فيها المقررات
مثل التربيه الاسلاميه او القران الكريم
وغير ذلك
هذا هو الفرق بين
المدارس في المغرب
والمدارس هنا في بلجيكا من ناحيه ديال
التدريس القران الكريم بالنسبه للامام
عمرو عادي امر عادي لا فرق بين المغرب
او غير بلجيكا باستثناء مساله التدريس
مساله التدريس هذا امر يحتاج الى عدد
النظر ان شاء الله الرحمن الرحيم
بعض الاخطاء
اعوذ بالله من الشيطان الرجيم
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
[موسيقى]
ولقد كتبنا في الزبور من
بعد ذكر ان الارض يرثها
عبادي الصالحون
[موسيقى]
ان في هذا
لبلاغا لقوم عابدين
[موسيقى]
وما
ارسلناك الا
متل للعالمين
قل
انما يوح
ان
ما الهكم
اله
واحد
فلنتم
مسلمون
فان تولوا فقلاء
ذاتكم على
سواء وان ند
ري اقريب
[موسيقى]
من بعيد
ما توعد
ون
انه يعلم الجهر من القول ويعلم ما تكتم
وا وان ندري لعله فتنه لكم
ومتاع الى حين
قل رب
احكم بالحق
وربنا الرحمن
المستعان على ما تصفون
صدق الله العظيم
بالنسبه للمسابقه الحقيقه حافز مهم
لتعلم القران الكريم
وتحفيظي على الاقل بعض صوره واجزائه هنا
في اوروبا عموما
ولذلك احيانا تنظم بعض المسابقات على
مستوى بعض المؤسسات
والمساجد وجمعيات
لان الامر يبقى
في حاجه ماسه الى المزيد من هذه المسابقات
سواء
المستوى المستوى الاول او المستوى الثاني
او الثالث او بالنسبه للاناث كذلك لابد من
المشاركه
وكذلك بالنسبه للجوائز احيانا تنظم بعض
المسابقات على مستوى بلجيكا وهذا وقع
لكن
بالنسبه للجوائز
هي تبقى دون المستوى مثلا اعطيك مثلا
الاول
يعطى له تذكره الحج
ومعلومه ان الاول والثاني والثالث
الفرق ليس كبيرا بينهما بمعنى انه اذا اخذ
الاول تذكره الحج في الثانيه ربما يكون
مقاربا له الى حد بعيد واحيانا يكون اذا
عدنا النظر
مشاركا معه في نفس في نفس المستوى
لذلك
هذا المسابقات تبقى دائما دون المستوى
المطلوب وخصوصا تكون موسميه كشهر رمضان
مثلا او بعض المناسبات الدينيه
فهذه المسابقات تحتاج الى
دراسه والى تخطيط والى من طرف اهل الميدان
المؤهلين
حتى تكون في مستوى حتى تؤدي
فائدتها وثمرتها المرجوه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات